un hommage digne des plus grands martyrs
de la république islamique mohsen
fakhrizadeh mort suite à une attaque à
la voiture piégée vendredi a eu droit à
des funérailles nationales
un public limité composée
essentiellement de militaires les
ennemis doivent le savoir ceci est leur
première défaite
si leur objectif était de tuer notre
cher martyrs pour faire oublier son nom
désormais son nom est louée par tous et
il est devenu une idole pour tous ceux
qui s'engagent sur la voie du combat
la cérémonie teintée d'émotion a laissé
place à un sentiment de revanche sur
leur ennemi juré israël comme un symbole
le cercueil du scientifique a été déposé
dans un important sanctuaire chiite dans
le nord de téhéran où reposent deux
autres scientifiques assassiné en 2010
et en 2011
l'iran a pointé du doigt israël dans ces
meurtres précédent comme dans celui ci
mais là où chemin
la nation iranienne est trop intelligent
pour tomber dans le piège de la
conspiration mis en place par les
sionistes
il pense à créer le chaos mais ils
devraient savoir que nous les avons
démasqués et qu'ils ne réussiront pas à
atteindre leurs objectifs maléfique des
accusations restées pour l'instant sans
réponse
benyamin nétanyahou sur les réseaux
sociaux est resté évasif
pourtant sur ces images tournées en 2018
le premier ministre israélien mentionne
le nom de ce scientifique tués lors
d'une conférence de presse sur les
dangers du nucléaire iranien et ce n'est
pas tout la responsabilité de l'état
hébreu prend de l'ampleur avec ses
déclarations d'un responsable israélien
new york times ce samedi il affirme que
le monde devrait remercier l'état hébreu
une formule reprise par l'ancien
ministre israélien de la défense
have no idea encore une fois je n'ai
aucune idée de ce qu'il a fait mais elle
que je peux dire c'est pourquoi cela
s'est produit et pourquoi il est
important et essentiel d'arrêter cet
effort continu massif de militarisation
de nucléaire
si on se réveille un matin dans un monde
tellement possède 2 305 armes nucléaires
ce nouveau monde sera terrible c'est que
ce sera un cauchemar pour tout le monde
pour les états unis pour la russie pour
tous c'est quelque chose que le monde
doit arrêter les autorités iraniennes
accusent également les moudjahidine du
peuple un groupe d'opposition en exil
d'être derrière ce complot
en tout cas cet attentat vient remettre
de l'huile sur le feu dans les relations
entre les etats-unis et l'iran joe biden
souhaite changer de cap
faire revivre l'accord de vienne par le
dialogue pour à un gel des recherches
nucléaires
sauf qu'en attendant la passation de
pouvoir donald trump et benyamin
netanyahou souhaite pousser leurs
adversaires dans ses limites
l'iran entre deux eaux doit choisir
entre des exigences de vengeance et une
volonté opportuniste de sortir de son
isolement